upward JLo and a rods date night run-in
with her ex guys is there anything worse
than running into an ex while you're out
with their new side piece well Jennifer
Lopez was this close from living out my
worst nightmare when she and a rod hit
up Craig's restaurant in West Hollywood
that's where her former flame beau
Casper Smart was also dining at the same
time let me remind you JLo and her
former backup dancer were together for
nearly five years and broke up in 2016
and then she started dating a rod and
eye witness tells et the exes did not
see or speak to each other adding it was
just a coincidence they were both there
but crazy that j.lo has had a public
run-in with beau Casper Smart before the
singer of bestie Leah Remini were having
a little girls die at a nightclub in LA
when the pair ran into him listen
there's something but love between the
former flames just last year beau told
us he's happy for JLo even though she's
moved on
I want nothing but the best and love you
know good friends you know I mean just
nothing but like respect and love for
each other
switching gears now to Christina
Aguilera the mother of two is working in
all white on the October issue of
Cosmopolitan and I'm digging this more
laid-back natural look from Christina
but you know what it wasn't long ago
that ex Tina was getting down and dirty
[Music]
Christina tells Cosmo how she really
felt about being pit against one-time
rival Britney Spears during that
stripped era where she of course debuted
a more provocative look quote I remember
being hurt by these commercials on MTV
pitting Britney as the good girl and me
as the bad girl it's like if I'm gonna
be demure and innocent that's okay but
if I'm gonna just be myself
I'm trouble before the record Christina
I listen to strip on repeat doing the
dirty choreography in my bedroom okay so
I'm team Christina all the way well
after that rebranding you know where she
were rebranded herself with dirty the
singer says she now appreciates the skin
she's been quote I love the female body
and I think it's something to be proud
of dirty was extremely controversial at
the time but it would be nothing now I
hope I paved the way
that's where Christina's love live it's
pretty tame she admits she prefers
dating men who aren't in the limelight
and so far she stuck to her word she's
been in a relationship with Matthew rut
ler since 2010 they met on the set of
burlesque he was a production assistant
on the film those who have yet to walk
down the aisle but has said Sharon beat
them to it and got fans all riled up
hinting that he may have already tied
the knot to cherry Seaborn and Ed's pal
et zone Kelty night try to get to the
bottom of it now I did see on your
Instagram that you told someone when
you're doing ask me any things that
you're maybe already married
I want to take this interview as if
you're not already married will you sing
at your own wedding no will you have
famous friends sing at your wedding will
you have someone unknown that you're
very passionate about sing at your
wedding so they get discovered not so
they get discovered but yeah okay
are you a groomzilla no do you know what
that is no always when you like when
you're like I need pee knees in pink
yeah I'm like I'm not a big I don't like
large groups of people that the best
that I'm so like yeah I don't I never
wanted a wedding that was loads of
people I know I got married in the
backyard yeah like it's a good boy
okay so ed stopped short of confirming
whether he's married or not but he did
refer the wedding and past tense there
well why for not that is also
celebrating the release of his Apple
music documentary songwriter which goes
behind the scenes of writing his Grammy
winning album divided and that's
streaming now okay real quick it is
national Power Rangers day and honor of
the 25th anniversary of my favorite show
as a kid now here's some proof of that
me and my sisters have it a Mighty
Morphin Halloween yeah as you can tell
that as a baby fat den as the Green
Ranger but respect I love my body okay
to celebrate Power Rangers turning 25
check out our original Pink Ranger Amy
Jo Johnson's thoughts on whether Tommy
and Kimberly ended up together I'll see
you guys tomorrow